wahlleiter ist schmeckt so gut
dass ich mir kräftig gestiegen also ich
schluss ich weiß auch dass es nur
[Musik]
hallo zu sammeln wir machen heute drei
richtig leckere dips die paste zum
grillen oder auch einfach zum abendessen
zu einem fernsehabend die passen einfach
immer also sucht euch eure lieblings
tipps auf und macht sie gerne nach ich
schreibe euch die ganzen zutaten und die
ganzen mengenangaben wie immer hier
unten in die infobox und ich will mal
sagen nicht lang schnacken kopp in
nacken oder halt noch mal anfangen wird
direkt an ich habe jetzt hier meine
auberginen das erste wird nur maschinen
gibt auch so typisch türkisch wobei
typisch orientalische besser gesagt und
die aubergine habe ich jetzt hier
einfach den kopf abgeschnitten
halbiert dann werden wir gleich mit
einer gabel ein paar mal ein stechen und
das ist nämlich der schritt der am
längsten dauert dann kommen die
auberginen in den backofen so mit der
gabel zu wirken wir einfach dass das
besser wird und schneller wird und die
aubergine halt schön weiter verwendet
werden kann nach dem backen
liegt ein bisschen brutal gerade aber es
muss sein und ihr könnt auf jeden fall
oder sollte auf jeden fall olivenöl
nochmal in die innenflächen geben
entweder olivenöl oder einfach letzte
einfachheit halber nämlich jetzt ein
olivenöl spray besprüht die innenseiten
und dann kommen die mit der in fläche
einfach hier auf meinen backblech und
dann brauchten diese ungefähr 30 35
minuten bis sie schön weich werden bei
220 grad ober unterhitze
[Musik]
schon jetzt einfach das innere der
maschine hier in unsere schüssel geben
ich kann euch das video aber das ist
jetzt aber nicht er war ich hab noch
jede maschine so richtig gesehen ist
mehr als voll komisch das ist dafür
zusammen drin bin sicher ich es einfach
so wie schmeckt mir nicht gesund ist
einfach aber das schmeckt doch in dem
dip schmeckbar stop erschienene so finde
ich auch nicht springt auf jeden fall
aber so pur ist einfach so das ist für
filme seien auf seinem t shirt anziehen
wird der bruch gesorgt hier perfekt
schritt ist wieder zu den tipps gibt
nichts besseres gebackenen dankeschön
klick ist kitchen haben ich habe
wirklich ein pdf vertrag nicht darauf
vergessen
ich hab noch nie so haben gesehene
oberkörper ich komme hier kann man sagen
dass ich wusste dass diese hat die leute
sollen wir schreiben wusstet ihr dass
operativ
hero berlin samen
die tik tok über dem einsamen haus
trotzdem dass irgendwo auf einem wechsel
wächst
du musst ja gleich wieder kommt ein test
es mache 36 heute insgesamt ok
so zu verschieben muss jetzt auf jeden
fall knoblauch dann habe ich hier salz
und pfeffer eingelegt hat die aubergine
schon ganz leckeren eigengeschmack in
dem dip also ich habe schon gesagt so
ganz ohne alles bin ich das nicht die
größte auberginen fand aber als dip
zusammen mit logos richtig lecker kommt
noch ein spritzer zitronensaft ein
bisschen säure darf doch noch mit rein
und dann wie gesagt der joghurt und ein
bisschen olivenöl gutes olivenöl und ein
verrühren wird dass ihr müsst es
eventuell gar nicht pürieren das reicht
auch schon eine gabel oder püriert
schnell durch hauptsache alles verbindet
sich gut und dann darf der auberginen
dip eigentlich noch mal so eine gute
stunde im kühlschrank ziehen er ist ja
auch noch war gerne auch zwei stunden in
die zeit habt und dann ist auch schon
fertig
[Musik]
ihr könnt jetzt auch ganz gerne noch
petersilie zum schluss mit dazu geben
[Musik]
so dick nummer zwei ist auch sehr
beliebt bei uns das ist ein dieb mit
getrockneten tomaten die findet er im
glas und die sind in öl eingelegt ihr
könnt auch die ganz ganz trockene nehmen
sind dann meistens in der obst und
gemüseabteilung
wir werden aber gleich sowieso noch ein
bisschen gutes olivenöl dazugeben und
die werde ich jetzt erst mal richtig
schön fein hacken ihr könntet eigentlich
das ganze auch pürieren auch eine
möglichkeit für beide varianten zeigen
also erstmal scheide ich das sehr sehr
freuen im anschluss werde ich auch noch
meine zwiebel richtig schön
feinschneiden und knoblauch pressen
[Musik]
jetzt ist alles hier beisammen mit dem
frischkäse und gibt jetzt noch salz und
ordentlich pfeffer mit dazu basilikum
ich vorhin auch schon mit dazu gegeben
passt einfach zusammen mit den tomaten
perfekt so dass ganze verrichtet dann
zeige ich euch mal so ist es halt er
stücke ich es könnt ihr auch machen gibt
ja solche und solche präferenzen und ich
mag sie aber wie gesagt lieber wenn man
das ganze dann püriert dann muss man es
auch nicht so fein schneiden dann hätte
man es im prinzip ganz grob alles
zusammen liegen können und theorien kann
also so ist quasi dann hier mit
stückchen so und ich werde jetzt für
ihren
[Musik]
so fertig ist der tomaten mit wenn ihr
mögt könnt ihr da wie gesagt noch ein
bisschen olivenöl drauf träufeln das
passt jetzt auch zu allen tipps und ganz
gutes olivenöl ist man schmeckt zeit
auch noch mal richtig lecker und ich
würde sagen wir gehen jetzt über zum
dritten tipp und das ist eine völlig
grad schon gesagt ich weiß aber auch
dass einer meiner favorite das ist ein
drittel war lustig und der geht auch
ganz berlin zeige ich euch jetzt so
natürlich brauchen wir für diesen tipp
datteln entweder nimmt ihr sehr weiche
daten die ihr dann entstand also zum
beispiel die mit schule davon könnt ihr
verwenden oder ihr nehmt direkt hatte
passte da ist quasi die ganze arbeit
schon erledigt die kennt ihr vielleicht
von meinen job in keksen kann man halt
süß und herzhaft verwenden und davon
nehme ich mir jetzt einfach ein stück
gibt dass hier gleich direkt in meine
schüsse zusammen mit frischkäse und
diesmal nämlich noch schwand mit dazu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nachdem wir das ganze dann püriert habt
natürlich knoblauch ganz ganz wichtig
gibt den knoblauch eigentlich auch immer
mit schale in mainz tritt viele wundern
sich dann immer und sagen hey dann hast
du doch schale bei dir in deinem dip zb
aber die schale wird hier aufgefahren
ganz einfach weg tun und dann wird sich
das ganze natürlich nicht salz und
pfeffer und was bei mir nicht fehlen
darf es pullback das sind paprika
vororten bis ein türkischer begriff die
sind schon so leicht die passenden noch
ganz gut mit dazu und curry wenn nämlich
einfach doug und carrie der kind insider
doch ihr könnt ihr alle oder nachdem ihr
das man verrückt bis der tipp auch
fertig besser ist es natürlich wenn der
deb jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen im
kühlschrank ziehen kann halbes stündchen
oder stündchen dann schmeckt einfach
noch ein bisschen besser
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch die walnüsse klein
gehackt um untergehoben ich mag das wenn
es ein bisschen kräftiger ist könnt ihr
machen könnt ihr auch weglassen ist
geschmackssache ich mag es ganz gerne
das ist gibt der wirklich super schnell
weg ist bei familienfeiern so isch de
kurs nochmal mit walnüssen und datteln
ich glaube ich mache so und dann passt
auch hier wieder ganz gut olivenöl
und dann ist auch fertig um lee gesagt
jetzt gerne nochmal im kühlschrank
ziehen lassen und dann haben wir
eigentlich alle sitze jetzt warte ich
noch auf hamza oder machen wir den test
es zusammen
[Musik]
so unsere unsere 3d und der ist
also ich freu mich richtig auskurieren
ich weiß was ich denken kann es mir klar
was wir gemacht das ist eher wahllos das
paprika
oder
so
[Musik]
ich habe hier schon gerade reingepumpt
sich nämlich nicht aus
sorry das schmeckt so gut man schmeckt
halt nicht nur diese getrocknete tomaten
aus vielmehr für mich zwiebeln knoblauch
und hält so es war einfach richtig froh
das ist richtig lief an der theke es
gibt ja von griechen oder türken oder
verband ist drin diese theke wo die
grenzen ganz
heftig aber ich finde dass also die
haben ja
gut an
die diese knoblich ist heftig die
strecke auch sehr lecker also ich finde
ich brauche eigentlich sein ich möchte
dich zeigen und sie lecker werden
so eine herbe los sein wenn wir bei den
eltern sind zum beispiel eine schwägerin
macht ihn auch mal ganz gerne der ist
immerhin mitbringt so heftig geschickt
also ich wusste was ich denke schon dass
es
[Musik]
mir halt diese süße note
ich bin ja nicht so fern von wald ist
also ein bisschen waldes erreicht das
ist doch genau das ist auch kein fan von
einzelnen zutaten aber soweit ich das in
etwas verbauen
lassen wird zu zweit gönnen rein
zufällig wurde deutlich bessere fertig
also das so ist es kein problem mit
bruder ja aber ich finde so ein frisches
baguette immer mit dazu ich würde sagen
heute macht die tipps gerne nach
ansonsten was wünscht ihr euch noch für
grill beilage von mir ich finde dass ich
das ganz richtig als grill beilage weil
für mich ist das das ganze jahr über die
attacken einen kommentar dann sehen wir
uns auch demnächst mal chillen
[Musik]